bad things to say when leading troops
into battle
soon you'll be at home with your
families in a jar on the mantlet
do you tweet no i don't tweet do your
facebook
yeah i did go on facebook what's your
name on facebook
frankie boyle
to be honest carol i'd heard you were
smarter than this
there are actually 57 frankie boyle's
pretending to be you
well i hope that they get the billet or
sexual assault case that i am jews
are you then we boys a [ __ ] wee boy
with a receding hairline how are you
doing benjamin button
you've been hit with a death ray or
something
well are you boy are you a [ __ ] sort
of fresh-faced old man what the [ __ ] are
you
maybe boy is this your parents [ __ ]
hell you brought
you brought two don't worry
your mum knows you wank
your mum wants to
sometimes your mum wants your dad
the only thing they don't know is that
you ain't thinking about your mum
wanking your dad
deleted lines from a fantasy film i'm
not a dwarf i'm a lesbian
if god created us all then god also
created gay people yeah
and the reason that god created gay
people was he knew that occasionally
we would need help getting the party
started
i thought it was sad you know that they
had that pop concert
to commemorate diana i mean she didn't
have much to do with pop music did she
they should have done something that
celebrated what was really great about
her life
by staging a gang bang in a minefield
lines you wouldn't hear in a superhero
movie
is it a bird is it a plane whatever it
is it's heading straight for the world
trade center
why has margaret been back in the news
this week she nearly died
or so i thought one block cheered over
there
there was a headline about her state
funeral so you suddenly go oh
she died no she's fine and yet we're
planning her funeral
but she's requesting she's she's one
involved in the family yeah she's
requested like saint paul's or some of
that and
no one's and everything's going yeah of
course you want to spell your name in
fireworks
i think it's good you know give her a
state funeral because
a lot of people will want to pay the
last respects
and a lot more people want proof that
she is really dead
it would be the first time that the 21
gun salute shoots the coffin
the worst person to be married to when i
said i was a positive person i meant hiv
uh thank you when are we gonna see you
back on tv on a regular basis uh
hopefully never at all
i'm trying to concentrate my charity
work
i'm helping teenagers who've been
sexually abused
find their way out of my house
you you have created you have please
in which that cannot be broadcast you
stand here dispensing awards
looking like a 500 pound haircut on top
of a pile of melting ice cream
well happy christmas everybody
we're still trying to get over pamela
anderson and vivian westwood man that
was well you know terrified
no that was like a before and after
shall i tell you why i'm like what i'm
like johnny i think i can explain myself
to you
when i was a wee boy my grandad
used to take me up into the loft
i'd take down a chest they had up there
he'd open up my chest
do you know what was in it a mermaid
and he'd have me stripped naked as a wee
boy and make
love to that mermaid on the floor while
he watched for his
sexual gratification now years later
when the old bastard was dead i went
back up into the loft
i took down the chest opened up do you
know what i found in there
a dead monkey with its legs sewn
together
you remind me of that monkey johnny
dear points of view watching queen eye
for the straight guy
made me think that if i made gay friends
they'd give me fashion tips
actually they [ __ ] me
things a new pope shouldn't say in his
first public speech
i only wish that hitler could have been
alive to see this moment
[Applause]
are you a weird looking straight guy or
a really weird looking gay guy
i'd come on your face just to cover it
up
that was your [ __ ] effort was it when
your mum gave birth she
shot you so she could leave her [ __ ]
free for [ __ ] the doctors
things you wouldn't hear on a driving
test when i slap the dashboard with my
forehead
i'd like you to crawl out of the
wreckage and fetch him
[Music]
bye